hauptstadt von frankreich werben hätte
jetzt sieht es bereits in kleinen
gewendet wir schauen uns heute mal
wieder witzige schüler antworten an
ja es wird wir absolut beschissen caesar
war sehr gut in rechtschreibung sonst
wäre er nicht diktator auf lebenszeit
geworden wo alter klasse 6 realschule
muss ich aber ganz ehrlich sagen das ist
so eine sache die ich früher vielleicht
nicht mehr in der sechsten klasse aber
früher in der grundschule wo man halt
wirklich noch die tat zu schreiben
musste diktate war noch dass das ist auf
der welt der lehrer hat einfach
irgendwas und man muss es aufschreiben
[Musik]
hätten das mal mit abi oder uni aber der
kleine luca hat sich auf jeden fall auch
die frage gestellt hey wenn jemand einen
diktator ist oder beziehungsweise war in
dem fall von caesar dann muss er ja
eigentlich gut in rechtschreibung
gewesen sein weil sonst würde er nicht
etwas diktieren was dann wir machen
weiter aufgabe stelle den verlauf der
französischen revolution da antwort dass
wir alles so schlimm dass selbst gott
den glauben verlor er hat ja eigentlich
den regen wird ziemlich karg für den ton
die köln ist halt irgendwie seit fünf
tagen nur ein bisschen kompletter
weltuntergang
[Applaus]
wahrscheinlich weil gott den glauben ans
wetter verlorener frage wer wurde im
jahr 1871 der erste deutsche kaiser
antwort dido westerwelle wird was also
real tor gehabt wie kommt man denn
darauf frage was wurde aus deutschland
nach dem ersten weltkrieg antwort arm
kleiner also an sich würde ich für die
antwort punkte geben da ist ja irgendwie
stimmt frage was macht der hitler 1938
antwort er sah aus dem fenster und
begann gurken zu pflanzen
was denken sich denn diese schüler dabei
steht das sind halt wirklich echte
antwort und schule hat nämlich dieses
buch hier noch wer sich gefunden und hat
das einfach mal durchgelesen hatte
daraus einige sachen abfotografiert und
deswegen habe ich jetzt die sache noch
nicht gesehen und der reagiert er gerade
live und euch drauf aber die sachen sind
wirklich von schülern also ich glaube
keiner von den abschluss geschafft frage
wie alt war jesus als er gekreuzigt
wurde antwort jesus war 33 als er
genagelt wurde an sich stimmt ja und ich
glaube auch jemand in der fünften klasse
weiß noch nicht richtig was genagelt
eigentlich für eine bedeutung hat trage
wie nennt man den urvater der drei
monotheistischen religionen antwort
avatar was ist monotheistische also ich
glaube der frage hätte ich auch aber
tagen geschrieben oder chuck norris
frage was sind die nördlichsten
deutschen
inseln antworte irland und der nordpol
die k-frage hauptstadt von frankreich
antwort danke dass ich schießen
[Musik]
also man muss wirklich sagen in
luxemburg ist es sehr wichtig so das
land heißt luxemburger die hauptstadt
von luxemburg heißt einfach
luxemburg-stadt in deutsche wälder
stadthalle ja das war als deutschland
und unsere hauptseite ist deutschland
statt
frankreich sind die erde dreht sich um
die eigene achse
das schlimme ist dass ich jetzt bestimmt
ja eigentlich hier dreht sich um die
eigene achse wer hat eigentlich achse
geschwistern dann axt die erde dreht
sich um die erste frage was sind die
merkmale eines nationalparks antwortet
der nationalpark wattenmeer ist ein
terrorist
[Musik]
man muss halt sagen es ist wieder eine
fünfte klasse in der in der
klassenarbeit wird das geschrieben ich
habe früher auch so komische fehler
gemacht und zwar mein vater einmal ganz
ganz gern die musik von sting gehört das
ist ein sänger der so geschrieben wird
und in einer klassenarbeit sollte ich
denn die vergangenheitsform von stinken
haupt schreibern ich hab stinkt
geschrieben welche an diesem sänger
getagt haben wahrscheinlich an dieser
schüler aus der fünften klasse halt
irgendwie gesagt hey nationalpark da
fällt mir ein nationalpark wattenmeer
als eigentlich ein touristengebiet aber
er hat irgendwie ein tierisch offenbar
bald frage welches körperteil sollte man
bei einem erdbeben besonders schützen
antwort das genital die sollte man jedes
körperteil schützen beim erdbeben also
von daher auch nicht so doll
unberechtigt frage welche aufgaben haben
die weiblichen bienen antwort sie putzen
viel kümmern sich um die kinder und
ihrer freizeit sammeln sie pollen und
nektar
das kann doch nicht echt sein hat wenn
das wirklich ein 6 letzter geschrieben
hat vor allem klasse 6 grundschule
klasse 6 ist nicht mehr grundschule
frage mit welchem heute lebenden vögel
kann man den archaeopteryx vergleichen
antworten sie immer alte frage welche
die ander thaler kennst du antwort ich
kenne keine weil sie alle
[Musik]
ich würde der volle punktzahl die frage
warum gibt es im weltall keinen schall
antwort weil dort die bäume dicht an
dicht stehen aus einer klassenarbeit
marie curie erfand die radioaktivität
und erhielt dafür einen oscar ja ich
meine katze dafür nicht bekommen aber
sind auf jeden fall preise bekommen das
ist eigentlich der nobelpreis oskar ist
schauspiel meine ich ertrage wofür wird
erdöl verwendet antwort salat
das ist tatsächlich die erste antwort
von einem gymnasiasten ja also ich meine
so blöd ist die antwort nicht erdöl wenn
man nicht weiß was genau erdöl ist
können wir noch denken das ist
gewonnenes irgendwie sonnenblumenöl
keine ahnung oder sonnenöl sonnenblumen
ich glaube ihr wisst was ich meine frage
haben alle länder der eu den euro
antworten nein die usa hat ja auch den
dollar das sind die geometrie profis
geometrie geometrie
frage was sind kennzahlen antwort dass
im zahlen die man in hessen klasse 13
wirtschaftsgymnasium
das kann nicht echt sein what i don't
know doesn't make him hot as we say in
germany aus einer fach- abitur prüfung
englisch ich glaube die hat der prüfling
nicht bestanden thema landkarten frage
was ist eine legende antwort franz
wiederwahl frage warum wird mit wasser
getauft antwort weil sekt zu klebrig ist
also
wieder eine typische luca aussage ich
hätte punkte gegeben so sekt ist klebrig
frage wie nennt man das ungeborene kind
im mutterleib an bord sombrero das ist
das ist ein ungeborenes kind im
mutterleib frage was sind die gefahren
von zigarettenkonsum antwort rauchen
verursacht samen
[Musik]
immer wenn mappus hat man einen samen
ägypter völlig richtig fünfte klasse
realschule
aber ich stelle mich das heutige video
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat diese
witzigen schüler an bord und dann lasse
gerne einen daumen hoch bei diesem video
ihr da schreibt mir gern und in die
kommentare was ihr denkt von den sachen
war das lustigste und was vielleicht
recht zu lustig war das ist echt sein
könnte ansonsten durch das video jetzt
allerdings auch beenden mit dem auto
[Musik]